since 1994 euros has connected employers  and job seekers across the european  union  the european economic area and  switzerland  supporting the free movement of workers  for over 25 years  but 2020 brought with it unprecedented  challenges  here at eurus we found new and sometimes  better ways to help employers and job  seekers  with over 2 million jobs and a host of  resources  on the euros job mobility portal we can  help you find work abroad  or the perfect employee we now offer  e-services  such as online personalized training and  advice  we continue to support with integration  for those living  in a new country we support workers who  live in one country  and work in another through our  cross-border partnerships  so as europe reopens for business  remember  that euros is still here to continue  supporting the free movement of workers  in the new postcode 19 world  you